and other news coming out of the NFC
South according to Adam Schefter of ESPN
Antonio Brown in New Orleans watch the
Saints today look here's the thing
here's the thing III hear there's and I
talked about this earlier in the year
one of the reasons that teams have not
signed Antonio Brown is they don't want
to have to pay him to not play because
if you sign him and the league puts him
on the commissioner exempt list you've
got a guy on your roster you're paying
game checks to while you wait for the
league to decide what they're gonna do
well the game checks are over now right
it's playoff share you're not even
paying the guys anymore that's all
league money so if they put them on the
commissioner exempt list fine they can
pay his playoffs share if they don't
want to let him play and and that's
that's the genius of waiting until now I
don't think the league is going to clear
him before the Super Bowl but the
question now becomes after waiting all
this time and not taking any action in
Antonio Brown if the Saints would sign
him would the league swoop in and say
you're on the commissioner exempt list
after they've had all these weeks to
make it known that they would put him on
the commissioner exempt list if he ended
up with another team I think the Saints
the Saints are putting the the league in
check here not checkmate but they're
putting them in check you're right there
they're boxing them in a corner a little
bit and yeah I guess there's two things
one you know okay the Saints are the
type of team and have the type of
culture that could certainly accept an
Antonio Brown why well once again there
are a team that could say like we don't
need you we're kind of good without you
or with you it doesn't matter so that's
always a good thing as far as the
culture with a guy like Antonio Brown
the second thing I think of is just
somebody with the Saints doing Antonio
Brown a solid I mean we've heard from
you know Antonio Brown's father on
Twitter he's not in a good place and all
those things
his Drew Rosenhaus Antonio Browns agent
called the Saints and said hey my guys
going crazy over here can we just get
him a workout so I can calm him down and
then third what do you get out of a few
of the Saints what do you get out of
that I don't know your consideration
maybe or maybe some prior you know maybe
yes maybe some deal down the lane
a favor be paying back a favor from the
past or extending a favor for the fuze
actly i mean that's how the NFL works
you and I both know that so it wouldn't
be shocked barely it's how politics
works - yeah well exactly and to your
last thing about like would he be
cleared if he saw I think you're right I
think if they signed him the NFL would
go no he's on the commissioner exempt
lasari we're not they're not gonna let
one of the premier teams go on a Super
Bowl run and we have to hear about them
and mistreating women and all that kind
of stuff no but it does force the league
and the league can't be happy about if
the league thought they'd be able to
kick the can all the way until the end
of the season right the Saints may stop
them from doing it up
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports